[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i always love
listening to nick wright first things
first on fox sports one
and i agree with a lot of things that he
says and then fritzi goes uh
nick wright's got a problem with you i
go okay
so what's the problem nick i hear you
don't like the picture we use
when we're promoting the fact that
you're gonna be on our show
well listen i mean i've been on tv a few
years i've been
a semi-public person for the better part
of a decade you have a lot of pictures
to choose from
yet you choose one where i have a shaved
head and a double chin
and i feel like this is
intentional i mean you have a you have a
army
of team around you mountain of resources
there's a lot of images
some flattering some not and some the
one you chose so
yeah i do have a bit of a problem with
that okay so you think that i went out
of my way to make you look
bad yeah i think
i'm not gonna name names here but there
is
an all-time pantheon great sports radio
host
who i believe once upon a time back in
the day
used to intentionally choose
bad fill-in hosts so when he
came back people were like oh my god
you're the greatest
i think dan patrick chooses
ill-f fitting pictures for his guests
so it's like man even in his older years
that dan patrick that's a good looking
guy
nick you chose boldness i didn't
you truly [ __ ] my head to add an
edginess to me
and it rose me to the heights
and then i grew my hair up i was afraid
of baldnick
i'm not afraid of this nick yeah i know
i'm soft
yeah that's true yeah that's true yeah
you are soft i i just would i got on a
a rant here i was wondering and let's
say when duran is done
steph curry's done like are they top 10
players of all time
and it and if so who are we taking out
because we can't have 15 guys in the top
10.
that is dan what a wonderful question
because i just completed i haven't yet
released it
uh a project i've been working on for a
year the 50 best players of the last 50
years
okay so kareem to now so
will russell elgin oscar jerry
mike and those guys are not being
included and on that list
durant is 12 steph is 13.
so ahead of them dr j
moses shaq i'm going kind of in reverse
order 12-1
shaq akeem bird
kobe duncan magic
kareem michael lebron there might have
been one name i left so doing off top my
head
but durant's durant's 12 steph is 13
according to that no i don't and if you
include
wilt and russell and jerry weston oscar
you got to move each of those guys down
another four spots
so no i don't think it's likely for
either of those guys to become top 10 of
all time
and if we're just doing the modern era i
think they could but like
you got to move past dr j and moses
malone
and then you gotta move past shaq or
akeem
just to get to the top ten at least in
my eyes i think dr j is totally
underrated but that's neither here or
there i saw him play against the
kentucky colonels
and aba
yeah that's why he's underrated oh my
gosh like i
i and i whenever he would play against
the nuggets i always felt bad for bobby
jones bobby jones was supposed to be
this defensive
star and dr j
left his great game on the playgrounds
and in the aba
and then what we got in philadelphia you
got to see glimpses
when they lost to the blazers in the nba
finals and doc
was so unbelievable in the nba finals
but
uh i'm with you i just don't i don't
know why he doesn't get recognized as
one of the top 10
15 players of all time because of the
because listen he was in the aba
and it is off top my head i think he won
three aba mvps think he won
the they didn't have a aba finals mvp
award they had a playoff mvp award
he won two or three of those he won
championships there and when he got to
philly
he did take them to four
nba finals at least three nba finals
they couldn't get over the hump
but they were up against awesome teams
and then once moses joins him
that might be the greatest team ever 83
sixers
86 celtics 01 lakers 2017
warriors are like you know all in the
argument
and probably i'm probably leaving out
one of the showtime lakers so yeah but
it's because his career is split
aba the nfl comp i would give not that
this is a top 10 guy 12 guy of all time
warren moon is historically underrated
because we just were like yeah he played
in the cfl and was great there it's like
no he was
the best player in the league by a mile
when he was there
that's what dr j was yeah dr j it's
almost like he got to the nba it's like
kareem in the 70s kareem in the 80s
it was a different player and you don't
realize how dominating kareem was
when he first got to milwaukee a couple
of things here better chance to reach
the nba fine i'm going to bounce around
here
please uh better chance to reach the
finals the nets or the sixers
sixers here's the here's the thing with
the nets
the nets are going to have the number
one offense in basketball i would be i'd
be
shocked if they even have the number two
offense
their offense is going to be so dynamic
and joe harris is going to become a
household name because he's going to hit
a million open threes
they are going to have a bottom five not
10 not 15 a bottom five defense
and i don't know how you solve it i just
don't know and you can't win
multiple playoff rounds with that type
of defense there's no historical
precedent for it
um the sixers on the other hand i think
are going to be good right off the bat
but their plan b is acquire james harden
so it's like they're either going to be
really good or if they're not
you just go acquire james harden because
there's not going to be a package for
him better than ben
simmons so i really and embiid
if you look at embiid's statistical
profile and remove last year
he looks like he's going to be a 30 and
15 guy two years ago embiid was 28 14
two and a half blocks went to game seven
you know against kawhi and the raptors
they lose on a bucket
he could have made the finals a couple
years ago last year was a down year for
him
he is lucas who i would bet on and who i
did bet on the nba won't give me a vote
for awards which is really criminal
there should be an investigation
but since i don't have one i can gamble
on it
so i bet a lot of money on luca but if
luca doesn't win it
my pick would be durant and then embiid
would be the top three
yeah i might go duran as well um
and and i i don't know if there's greek
freak fatigue
he can't win it no way
well i'm guessing he probably can't
because okay
let's say he averages what he averaged
or improves a little bit and their best
record
in basketball we've seen all of these
things
and it feels like the voters want
something new
and like in the last 50 years
the only guy to win three in a row was
bird and bird was doing it in the midst
of winning titles
yeah and it's like wow he's really he's
just the best player in the league on
the best team
i think that one of the reasons i like
luca
is i think giannis is a i think giannis
could average 34
17 and six and won't win it
harden no chance at winning it he's in
in it every year but i feel like his
nobody's going to reward how that's
going right yeah
lebron is going to play fewer games this
year than maybe he has
at any point in his career anthony davis
it's hard for me to believe
voters at the end of the year are going
to be like you know what the most
valuable player in the league is a guy i
know
isn't the most valuable player on his
own team so that hurts anthony davis
for steph the warriors are going to be
fighting to make it to the playoffs
so now who are we talking about you know
what i mean you're like running out of
people
i think kd is a really good option but i
think luke is going to average
30 10 and nine
and if that team's a top four seed that
that'll win the mvp
i i like to watch bad teams nick but i
have to invest in a bad player on a bad
team
or a good good good player on a bad team
i should say so
lamelo ball has come to my rescue i'm
all in on lamello ball i'm all in
i think he is he makes them the hornets
not must-see tv
but must stop to watch a little bit
of them which would be a new phrase here
but i don't know where you stand on
lamello ball but
i'm all in well you know you haven't
asked me about gambling so i'll bring it
up a second time not that i have an
issue i bet a lot of money
a year because i think that
i think people are going to consume the
hornets just like that
lamelo is going to have knights where
he's 3 for 17. guess what no one's going
to know
but he's going to have nights where he
shows up all over sportscenter
and sportscenter that's the thing people
used to watch first things first on fs1
is where they go
um and he's going to be top of mind the
warriors want to win
so i don't think weissman is going to
get you know necessarily all the minutes
all the touches
and then we i know ob topping is like a
popular pick with the knicks i don't
know
i think lamelo is going to have good
numbers
and good highlights and it's not an
overwhelmingly strong rookie class i
know that's unfair to say they haven't
played a game yet but
in my eyes it's not i think lamella is a
good pick i think lamelo also is going
to be
better than his brother
no i do too i mean i think he's a
legitimate match-up problem he can get
to the hoop right hand left hand
uh his shot while it's too low for me
uh at least it's you have to at least
acknowledge it on defense but
um i like him now the reason why i was
going to have you on
believe it or not was you said something
about the kansas city chiefs
where you talked about them this might
be the best road performance that we've
seen and i'm paraphrasing here yeah
uh because i'm usually combing my hair
and putting makeup on while i'm you know
listening to first things first because
i like to see jenna wolfe on there
um the the chiefs are having
historically
one of the greatest road seasons
of all time right yeah okay i mean
so they're eight no on the road eight
teams have ever
done that and what they've done on the
road is
beat pre-season super bowl co-favorite
baltimore
at the beginning of the year before
baltimore had shown some weaknesses
went to miami scored 30 consecutive
points when miami was playing at its
best
went to tampa when tampa was playing its
best
beat them went to new orleans and i
understand brees was obviously not
himself
but controlled that game and take away
what the saints offense did the saints
defense had been
number one in football for six weeks
hung 32 on them
went to oakland when oakland was six and
two or six and three
and avenged that loss their one loss the
year and went to buffalo
and beat them and their other two road
games are
the divisional games chargers game very
early in the year and annihilating
denver
i mean you've got six road victories
over playoff caliber teams and three
over the five super bowl co favorites
essentially or
the five or the six so yeah i just i i
feel like
it's hard to show me a season where
someone had a better road performance
these numbers concern me though nick and
and tony dungy was on first hour and he
said
i think the chiefs are bored they won by
two
four three six six three in their last
six games they've won the games
they allow teams to hang around and
that's that's what's interesting come
playoff time for me
so allow me i'm gonna glance down
because i have this saved on my phone
the the final margins are not overly
impressive
what is impressive is they're never in
jeopardy
so by that i mean the last time the
saints had the ball
with a chance to take the lead midway
through the third quarter
for the dolphins it was in the second
quarter for the bucks
it was in the first quarter for the
bills it was in the third quarter for
the ravens it was in the second quarter
so they certainly take their foot off
the gas get bored
a lot but they they seem to they never
there hasn't been a moment in the last
two months where it's like man
if the chiefs they have to get this stop
or they
lose the only game that came close that
was carolina when joey sly was kicking a
67-yard field goal
to try to beat him like that wasn't a
real thing and
i do think dan if you the saints game
listen it shouldn't been as close as it
was and the chiefs are just just
addicted to letting teams back door
cover i mean
they've won six in a row and didn't
cover any of the games
that never happens but i
the saints scored that touchdown with
206 left and two timeouts
against every team in all of nfl history
you kick off and try to
you stop him i do wonder if against the
chiefs you have to consider on sidekick
there
if it's like if we give it to my homes
he needs a first down he's going to get
it
like he's just going to get it so i just
i think this is team is not going to
lose until next season sometime
he's nick wright fox sports won and
you've angered the
bald community because you can grow hair
you wanted an
edge and you shaved your head and now
you're kind of thumbing your nose at the
bald nick wright
here's poor todd fritz todd can't todd
once look like mark ruffalo
and take the hat off todd like
nick should understand that like
dan somewhere in america there is a
bald man who loves the los angeles
clippers
and lives in buffalo new york and roots
for the bills
and if i ever show up missing he's the
number one
subject there's someone who all of my
sports commentary and my
follicle greatness if we will has is it
just
it represents everything he hates in the
world i don't think that's todd fritz
but
fritz he's from brooklyn and he roots
for the broncos
oh i'm sorry broncos and astros
yeah astro's fine it's tough to win when
you don't cheat but that's fine
uh next time you're on yeah we're going
to show
this right here this look right there i
hope you're wearing the same sweater
you know what maybe you got a baby
picture maybe you send in one you know
that your wife has one that you
you know like little baby hot takes
we'll just say nick wright's joining us
for baby hot takes
little baby hot takes merry christmas
thank you nick you too thank you bud
thank you nick that's nick wright fox
sports one it's first things first